le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
chaque année près de dix mille jeunes
réunionnais se lance dans les études
certains restent sur l'île d'autres
s'envole vers la métropole
mais pour tous se posent la question des
finances aux portes de l'indépendance
comment assumer les frais d'inscription
le loyer ou les besoins quotidiens
depuis des années le département propose
le dispositif net bourse
un ensemble d'aidés financières pour
permettre aux jeunes réunionnais
d'entamer l'esprit tranquille
leur nouvelle vie étudiante
[Musique]
pour passer les portes du laboratoire il
faut montrer pas de bleus en a lancé une
pcr traduire une amplification
des échantillons d'adn n qu'on a
récupéré et là je vais remettre du thin
dessus pour pas qu'ils aient
d'évaporation de contamination mais yumi
20 ans est en stage au cirad depuis deux
semaines elle travaille au pôle de
protection des plantes à saint pierre
un projet
qu'ils s'appellent le projet épices bio
c'est un projet de coopération en fait
dans toute la zone
aussi le mendiant et moi je travaille
plus particulièrement son les
champignons qui te pathogènes ces
champignons
ce stage intervient dans le cadre de ses
études d'ingénieur des études qu'elle
effectue actuellement en métropole
je suis donc pour en première année dans
une heure en biotechnologie à bordeaux
ça m'intéressait particulièrement de
travailler ici puisque je suis quand
même attaché à mon île et pouvoir
travailler sur des problématiques qui
concernent de la maison est important
pour moi
pour la jeune femme c'est aussi
l'occasion de rentrer au bercail la
maison familiale n'est qu'à quelques
minutes du cirad
à l'heure du déjeuner mayumi retrouve sa
mère et sa soeur
voilà 8 mois qu'elle a quitté le nid
pour continuer ses études sur bordeaux
c'est la plus grande et c'est la
première à partir c'est très dur c'est
très dur on a volé bon on a beau le
savoir on a beau savoir que nos enfants
sont amenés à prendre leur envol
c'est quand même une déchirure qui est
quand même très important quand on la
dépose à l'aéroport à la peine vient
s'ajouter la question des finances
billets d'avion loyer transport subvenir
à tous ces besoins peut être un
casse-tête pour les parents on regarde
toutes les aides qui existent parce
qu'en plus de ça moi voilà je suis seul
à lesquels je travaille bon c'est vrai
que j'ai beaucoup de charme
c'est la grosse problématique pour
réussir à faire en sorte qu'elles
puissent poursuivre leurs études après
on a de la chance c'est que mes yumi a
été elle a eu le bac avec mention très
bien félicitations du jury
donc de ce fait là elle a eu en plus de
sa bourse nationale
la bourse au mérite plus nettement ce
cas suivi derrière et c'est vrai que ça
pour ça elle a réussi à un taux à
s'autofinancer
sincèrement si ma fille avait pas eu ces
aides là c'était pas possible moi je
n'avais pas possibilités financières de
la compagnie pour bénéficier de ces
aides
mais youzhny est passé par une
plateforme internet unique net bourse
ça a été assez facile surtout pour le
netbook parce que on peut mettre
maintenant tous les papiers qui sont
intéressants qu'ils demandent de la
plate forme internet
on s'est beaucoup plus simple que encore
devoir envoyer par la poste net bourse
c'est d'abord un site internet
depuis peu la plateforme regroupe toutes
les aides existantes pour les étudiants
pour le département trois aides
principales la bourse départementale la
location scolarité et le logement en cu
et notre souhait le plus cher au
département et l'ensemble des élus c'est
de porter notre jeunesse vers le
parcours d'excellence pour une insertion
professionnelle durable
tous les ans à peu près dix mille
exclusion bénéficier de nous aide au
niveau du département notamment les
bourses départementales la location de
scolarité la cellulite est un qui est
dédié aux étudiants qui souhaitent aller
se former en métropole notamment à paris
et donc c'est un dispositif unique en
france
une offre plus lisible notamment pour
les jeunes bacheliers comme maël qui
vient de passer son bac j'ai répondu à
toutes les questions pour l'instant je
pense que j'ai montré que j'étais motivé
à la voir et que jamais les
connaissances pour donc voilà je pense
je pense qu'il est bien parti
comme pour la préparation de ces examens
bah elle a déjà bien organisé son avenir
moi je vais faire une licence de psycho
pour pouvoir faire les spécialités en
criminologie après et j'espère aller
jusqu'au doctorat pour faire prof de fac
après et faire des recherches et j'ai
calé pour l'accompagner sur ce long
parcours
la future étudiante s'est tourné vers le
dispositif net bourse
dans cette première fois que je faisais
un peu de paperasse et du coup je me
suis sur internet et les marches - s'est
jamais expliqué on à l'inscription du
comté a proféré à mesure et de poser
question moi on peut le faire facilement
tout seul
couplé au soutien de ses parents c'est
ed renforcera l'indépendance de la jeune
fille va mon loyer ça va être plutôt les
parents qui vont gérer mais ça a plutôt
aidé à tout ce qui est bien pour mes
cours
tout ce qui est l'outil matériel à
manger
à faire mes courses mais sinon oui pour
ma vie quotidienne en fait ma elle a été
acceptée sur montpellier
pressé de commencer sa nouvelle vie
d'étudiante elle est déjà en pleine
recherche d'appartements ont quitté la
réunion ça me fait toujours un peu peur
parce que j'ai tout ici et mes potes
chez un peu ouais j'ai mes habitudes
j'ai ma famille pour tout ça va être un
peu galère sinon je suis assez pressé de
commencer à vivre ma vie d'étudiante
du coup je suis assez précis et d'y
aller
[Musique]
chaque année les inscriptions sur net
bourse se font de mars à octobre
les demandes se font via des formulaires
en ligne au nom de l'étudiant
les étudiants peuvent prétendre
principalement à la bourse
départementale attribuées sur critères
de ressources familiales à la location
de scolarité pour les parcours
d'excellence et à des places en cité
internationale universitaire de paris
pour tous renseignements rendez vous sur
le site www.sncf.com 7,4 points est re
ou au numéro vert 0 800 800 596
[Musique]